yeah hot Lana mamitu is a continuation
of the events of hotline many one and it
falls a bunch of different groups that
he'll have connections and some more
former fashion to the events of the
first game so they this group that we're
watching now is the fans are basically
copycat killers they are infatuated with
what happened in the first game and
they're basically trying to recreate
that kind of dinners and events but then
you'll kind of follow the narrative
throw but the eyes of a bunch of
different folks so there's a there's a
detective and there's I don't know
there's about three or four different
kind of variables and their narratives
you're going to go through
some of them change up the gameplay that
you're familiar with quite a quite a bit
and so that's going to basically a man
it's more the same in a sense but it
changes up the it changes up the plot
quite a bit can you go into the
specifics of like some of the new play
styles and like what a speed are doing
right now that's play with the Swans
wings and the front one uses a chainsaw
in the back one fires with the right
mouse button so you're able to get a
control to care for one time and do a
lot of damage but there's a bunch of
different mass tiles that you use to
figure out you know your play what you
like there's a bear that has double
newsies the detective has some kind of
special gameplay features the zebra does
a special role so instead of this little
perks now they actually have a special
move it's kind of an interesting dynamic
I mean it's it's it maintains the same
foundation that kind of twitch aspect
that space trial-and-error dying and and
trying to you know figure way through
every level but at the same time I think
you know there's things like the boss
battle some people were kind of
frustrated with the boss battles won
first game so Dennis on the developer is
going through and kind of making a lot
of changes on how they approach those
things and what that means and then like
I said the gameplay variables really
like how can we take this formula and
make it more interesting so fans will
kind of feel familiar with it but also
throw us a couple screws at screwballs
in there to kind of mix it up
you